[Music]
luke is going to start off this hour in
detroit hey luke what's up
hey everybody thanks for taking my call
sure man
yep so i'm 28 years old and looking to
purchase my first house and i'm calling
wondering if i should include things
like stock compensation and yearly bonus
in my total compensation when figuring
out
what a budget for a house would be yes
okay yeah 25 percent 25 of your
take-home pay annually regardless of
where it comes from bottom line is do
you have money
to pay the house payment
at a fourth of your hou income
and still have money left over to live
life well that's what this is it's not a
it's not like some kind of nuanced thing
that if you're off three tenths of a
percent
on your uh ratios or something that
you're going to go broke that's not the
thing the point is don't buy a stinking
house where your house pays 50 of your
take-home pay you ain't got any money
and you're gonna end up taking out a car
payment when the car breaks
got it yeah i was more kind of concerned
with
including things like stock and even
side gigs really just because of if like
the stock tanks i mean you were kind of
depending on getting one chunk of it
well if it's a big portion of i mean if
it's 50 of your income then i'd be
worried about it but it's not it's five
percent
got it so if you got zero it doesn't
change your life and you'll probably get
it the next year
got it and your income is going to go up
after you buy the house too
over time agreed okay
yep yeah so that's the other thing the
whole thing about the 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed rate
ratio is just simply to keep you from
getting yourself strapped to the wall
all in the name of oh god i live in
california and math doesn't count here
or stuff like that right of course it
counts there math works everywhere and
so it keeps you from getting emotional
and doing some stupid butt thing because
you
you figured out that's the only house in
the whole world that you can live in or
something that's what the ratio is for
is to make you think clearly and instead
of using the emotional side
of your brain because we all use the
emotional side of our brain when making
uh financial decisions and they seldom
work john never works man i we bought a
house last year that that that ratio
provided a great anchor for us like just
a place to stay tethered into
and
we searched for nine months and the
housing prices were escalating the whole
time and then the the people were
getting more and more dramatic but
always knowing let's let's this is our
this is our anchor point here man that
provided so much stability it provided
me and my wife a place like almost like
home base we could always go back to and
say we're gonna stay here you know and
it that's what it is that's what the
stuff we give you guys out there these
guidelines we give you these steps we
give you and everything else is an
anchor point it just goes okay here's
where common sense is to the extent
you're not lined up with that
you're probably about to make a mess
bubba i mean that's all we're saying
right so for me it's simple i don't
borrow money for anything right so my
anchor point is do i have the money
that's a i have to start there right
dave how is that how is that crazy i
mean isn't that weird but i have to
start with us well i mean and it gets
big and my world has gotten big like we
just bought a piece of ground next doors
you know
a bazillion millions of dollars right 22
acres next door over here and for for
the for this complex this ramsey
freaking campus thing going but even
that i'm looking at this massive and
it's a nice investment it's a great real
estate investment in a wonderful area
and thrilled we did it but you know
winston rachel's husband does our real
estate we're sitting there looking at it
and we had to ask ourselves like we're
in
uh like we're in the
grocery store line we want to buy a pack
of gum you know do we have the money
right and uh if we don't the answer is
we can't even look at this deal
i i
just there's something brilliant about
the complexity of that
you know how rare it is that i'm
speechless and i'm speechless at the
idea
that it sounds crazy to think as a
business owner of a
multi-million dollar corporation to
think
do i have the cash to pay for that
and that just sounds that that puts you
in the i bet there's one percent of one
percent of business owners in the
country that run their machines like
that but you know what the other thing
is it does and it does it in your
personal life it does it in whatever
you're doing whatever it is you're doing
there's just
a lot of peace yeah
in that simplicity yeah and um and you
know people make fun of me you know you
don't understand this you're not
sophisticated and i'm like crap man i
can pencil whip all of you that say that
stuff i understand the other stuff but i
also understand how i feel
when a pandemic hits and i don't have
any payments oh anybody anything yeah
you know i also understand that i always
seem to have money
because i don't have any payments
you know it's just these are kind of
basic
stuff you know but it it there's a
cleanliness to it of the soul yeah of
your spirit um i mean you talk a lot
about trauma on your show and even calls
that come in here and in the books and
things and uh uh you know it's there's a
thing i guess we need to do a book
someday on financial trauma absolutely
what it does to you to stay geared up
wired up jacked up all the time about
your freaking life because you bought a
bunch of crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't really like this is a bad
chemistry it does stuff to the body i'm
learning from you it melts you from the
inside out it's like it's like dumping
drano down your sink once a year to get
a hair clog out
it's not great but it's fine but if
every morning you just get up and dump
drano down your sink just to dump draino
down your sink because that's just the
way i live it's gonna eat through the
pipes it'll rot your pipe that's right
don't make a mess man some of you got
rotten pipes
and you know i live that way because
you're just living from stress to stress
right it's like being you know in poor
control of your time christie's book
take back your time when you t when you
take back your time and you take back
your money
man
just a lot of peace you know i was
reading the book a couple of months ago
david was talking about
some ways to
just live a little more peacefully
and one of the things that suggested was
this
just for the next week drive the speed
limit
oh now you're going to meddling no
listen man
i tried to drive the speed limit
i thought i was just walking no that's
not peaceful for me that's quite the
opposite no but listen i did it for a
week just just just to prove it
and i tell you what i got to work
i had to leave a little bit earlier a
lot earlier a lot a lot earlier but i
got to work and you had no fun i wasn't
frazzled
i didn't feel like i was
being electrocuted it was just again
it's a different way to do life i think
that we have sped up the world so fast
so quickly so with so much bonkers
advice we don't even know what feeling
good feels like if you never turned on
the news for the next 10 days
at all at all
it's all gonna happen anyway
yes
and and if you're just gonna feel
so much somebody will text you so much
better listen just tune in here if
something big is going on we'll tell you
but we're probably not going to bring it
up so because there's not much big
enough for it to make in the new cycle
for it to make it to this show because
we're a big deal and we don't really
want to talk about that stuff